[Applause]
foreign
all right
[Applause]
what it is I'm Tyrus and I'm in for the
little fella but he sent a clip of what
he's been up to check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
and he was the tall one
as for me many of you have heard I have
retired from wrestling
it's okay but I'll still choke slam
anyone who asked for Joe Mackey's
pronouns
[Applause]
but now that I'm retired I can focus on
other things
like my kids
are helping out around the house
cutting the grass
fixing the water heater
cleaning out the garage
Maybe
organize my closet
I might find a pair of long pants that
actually fits
who knows maybe I'll see more books and
read more movies
yep and I'll be home all the time
all the time
all
[Laughter]
all the
no I know what I can do I can solve
world hunger
that'd be easy for me all I had to do is
skip lunch
okay maybe not
but I know one thing I can bring this
country together
now I'm strong enough to pull Alaska
south to join the rest of us
I could even run for president
but I'd have to be twice my age
[Applause]
and up
now here's my plan and it starts to top
and that's not just because I'm taller
than everyone
now instead of having presidents get his
political opponents mug shots we can
just drain mugs and take shots
foreign
and not the felony kind like in Chicago
that's right let's make America drunk
again
[Applause]
if that was political
remember when we all loved beer
Enchanted tastes great less filling it
tasted horrible but we didn't care
either way no matter what your political
affiliation we all agreed we love beer
well actually we love the beer
commercials more than the beer no matter
what it was beer bottles playing
football
dogs drinking beer at pool parties
beach volleyball seem popular anything
was possible you heard what's up you
yelled back what's up
now what happens now when you see a beer
commercial
ew
it's not supposed to be there's more
filling in the front of the
spokeswoman's swimsuit
ew
but it starts at the top and no not Top
surgery
foreign
that's right
we have to respect old Corn Pop
Hail to the 157 year old chief
yeah that's right
he's our president too
[Laughter]
I'm not gonna let you give me the silent
treatment
or you or boo but he's the president
and if you are mean to him it could ruin
his vacation
now look
everyone's mad because he said no
comment when they asked him about Maui
Fair he thought Maui was the name of one
of his granddaughters
I'm kidding I'm kidding
I say we have to find common ground on
things
for example
our president is so cool that he can
talk to dead people
remember when talking to dead people was
cool when the little kid from Sixth
Sense said I see that
we all loved it
I wish I had that power
now I can throw a man through a brick
wall but after that
conversation is kind of dull
but when the president talks to ghosts
everyone's got a damn problem
I wish I could
shake hands with a ghost
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what
I would love to see a ghost as long as
he's not wearing a white sheet
hey
and did you ever think for one second
that maybe the ghosts were shaking his
hands and introducing themselves to him
because they were trying to bring him to
the light like in Poltergeist
Caroline
okay so not so much in the ghost okay
cool all right
how about ice cream
we all love ice cream
and recently our president went to the
ice cream parlor and I for one was proud
of him because he was there for ice
cream
[Laughter]
and the Press followed him and of course
they were there to ask him questions but
they were a little nicer to this
President than the previous
administration
so they allowed him to order his little
delectable treat
and he got his little ice cream
and we all remember what happened
he took his ice cream he took his bite
Mr President
how cold does your mouth have to be
to not melt ice cream
now I know some of you are going to say
it was chocolate chip
chocolate melts too
then it hit me yeah
he's dead
[Laughter]
hear me out he talks to dead people
he follows ghosts he can't melt ice
cream
zombie apocalypse
[Applause]
he's not smelling hair
smelling brains
[Applause]
I've watched enough Walking Dead to know
a zombie when I see one
nobody Falls walking upstairs but
zombies
you see him with that baby zombie
[Applause]
that's some zombies right there
forget it everyone for themselves
barricade your doors remember earlier
when I said the beginning of the show
that we got to be positive
well I lied to you America
the only thing I'm positive of is this
is a zombie apocalypse
so we all have to stick together
and if we all win maybe just maybe we
can make America alive again
[Applause]
yeah all right let's welcome tonight's
guests the greatest thing about his
books is they become movies novelists
and literary critic Walter Kern
[Applause]
ERS posted the Michelle Tafoya podcast
the one and only Michelle Tafoya
his shows are like sex it's just two
people having a good time comedian Joe
Mackey
[Applause]
she may be petite but she knows how to
compete Fox News contributor in New York
Times best-selling author the cat too
all right cat
how do we fix division
in this country what would be your move
if they if you called you up the White
House called your day and said Tim fix
this what would what would it be I think
that honestly they would just have to do
less oh yes you know it wouldn't be
they're too involved and everything is
so personal because politicians they
want it to be personal because if we
hate each other the more that we hate
each other then the more or the less
that we're focused on you know what
they're doing and the more that they can
convince us to be afraid of each other
and we'll you know make the case for
policies that take away more of our
rights
you said I didn't have to be positive so
no I did yeah yeah Walter now before I
get into you so Walter knew I lost my
title right you know I get it and we now
both will own land in Montana and before
the show he gave me another title he
made me a sheriff of my property so I'm
very excited because now I'm Law and
Order
thank you
and because I wear glasses now and I
have the shakes I'm a little afraid to
put it on so I'll get it on there later
Walter you've seen it all and I in the
monologue I was joking but there was a
time when we found common ground and
something as silly as a beer commercial
everyone was always talking about it how
have we gotten so far away from at least
being able to agree on one thing
uh Greg Gutfeld had a lot to do with
that actually
um I I think he's divided the nation
more than almost anyone
I'm glad you're bringing about damn time
somebody Pat and I have been saying this
privately yeah but we just say Craig
Butterfield yeah remember when all the
late night hosts agreed and then Greg
came along and gave another perspective
yes America's never recovered from that
um
but you know I was sitting here trying
to think can I find something nice to
say about President Biden you know what
could it be in the spirit of healing
and I thought I think the thing I admire
most about him is that he insists on
walking upright
um
[Laughter]
you know he's at an age and he's in a
kind of shape where he could easily have
a wheelchair or a scooter wheelchair one
um
he can put a little flag on the back and
have like a boom box on his lap playing
you know the Star Spangled Banner
um so his insistence on being a bipedal
upright human being uh despite all you
know all the setbacks he's faced I think
it's something we can all cheer for
thank you
Michelle you being one of the greatest
interviewers in sports history you were
in the middle of some of the greatest
rivalries in sports but even with the
rivalries it was a certain amount of
respect there
we there is no respect anymore when you
disagree on something as simple as
politics
do you have with all your you've I'm
sure you had to interview people who
couldn't stand each other did you were
you ever in a situation we had to bring
it together with one common thing yes
but you know I've I've all long believed
that everything starts in the schools
with kids when they're very young and I
think our school system in America is
absolutely sick right now like it's ill
like it's got a cancer so I have an idea
for you now that you're retired right I
think we make you Secretary of Education
or because you've got an educational
background right that's the rumor yes
got some free time now you're a big guy
No One's Gonna question you and I don't
have to go home and you don't have to go
home
I'm like you know you will not have to
go home but and then I and you you've
made a living by fighting bullies in the
ring right yes you and Randy Weingarten
in the ring the the head of the American
Federation of teachers and you take her
down and then you set the rules in
education and you make education great
again in America that's what Tyler
should do
that's that's the lady who talks with
her arm right yes she does a lot of this
yeah
she's just Mackie you're always in
controversy women fighting over you
wherever you go you can't you can't even
sit down for a meal of food without
being hit on as a sex symbol who has to
deal with breaking up cat fights all the
time how do you find common ground to
get both sides to agree to just look and
admire you I say ladies there's plenty
of me to go around okay all right I'll
say Tyrus congratulations on retiring
you had a great career and now that
you're out of the way all my roadblocks
to the title are clear you're going down
EC3 it's going to stand for X champ when
the ref counts to three okay
and I don't
[Applause]
I don't understand what like what kind
of zombie Joe Biden is because I mean
like what kind of zombie has his dogs
bite people for him
he's a lazy zombie obviously
[Music]
even zombies get old
I don't know if that's to be true all
right before we go reminder to come out
and check out my Live Events my stand-up
comedy show I'll be in Alabama Virginia
Tennessee Texas and more go to my link
Tree on my Instagram or my Twitter for
ticket information hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else